新京报的朋友们大家好
我是cindy
王心凌
那一定就是我在想你
如果半夜被手机吵醒啊
那是因为我关心
若不失去理智
爱情要从何开始
傻傻的骗子和骗人的傻子才可能一生一世
那年夏天我和你短暂
所以今年来参加乘风破浪这个节目之前
知不知道在这边有那么多的心灵麻烦
对他们有什么样的印象
就是说啊不知道心灵男孩都长这么大了
然后都成家立业了
然后上有老下有小了
就是啊早期的时候来的时候有很多粉丝
然后因为这次乘风破浪的关系
看到长大后的他们其实不止心灵男孩
其实也有一些心灵女孩
心灵大女孩已经当妈妈了
可能之前我在有一些比较可以近距离
后面的活动
他先从带着男朋友来
然后到带着老公来
然后到带第一个小孩
到太两个小孩对
就是觉得蛮特别的嗯
就是我真的陪他们一路
真的是长大成成家
这样就陪伴他们走过的青春吧
他们也陪我走过我的青春
我觉得因为我还比较早出道
我差不多20岁左右出道
所以其实也算是一个
有点像是一个相互陪伴的关系
那你会怎么样形容自己的青春呢
我的青春啊
如果要说20岁之后的话
我都献给了工作
就是你知道18 20岁的年轻人
可能会去蹦迪啊
然后唱k啊
嗯呃偶尔放纵自己
跟朋友玩到天亮才回家
这些我都没有
我只有拍mv
拍到天亮回家
所以我的青春我觉得就是呃给了我的工作
然后给了我的歌迷朋友们
可是也因为有这样子的付出
才有现在的王心凌
没想我们还是天天在那
这是一种女生俱来的天赋和魅力
你自己在什么时间会有自己的天赋表现多一点
可能打从妈妈生给我这个圆圆的脸
圆圆的眼睛开始
就是我看起来的样子
就就不是那种很酷的女生
就算我打扮的很酷
就好像还是差那么一点点
就是我的酷可能还是要就是可甜美中带点酷
那小时候也是就是也没有不是那么清楚
是我觉得比较清楚
可能是我第一张专辑
那时候打到第四波的主打歌叫丹尼
然后是黄中平导演拍啊拍摄的mv
然后因为那只v当时是穿上我高中时候的制服
然后中平导演用一个嗯我很自然的样子去拍摄
然后只有那支mv就反而就是受到大家的回响
跟那个样子就是是被大家喜欢的
可是那样子其实比较接近真实的
我因为会艺人出道到他成长
能够给观众一种固定的印象
其实非常成功的
但是呢你有没有自己会不会感受到
这种固定的印象
会有另外的一面
就是会对自己有一些限制的一面的
我没有什么好觉得限制的
因为她就是我的一部分
就是甜美就是我特色
她就是与生俱来的其中一个样子
然后前美甜美并没有一定要傻白甜
虽然我也蛮白的
她她也可以是一个呃温柔而坚强
温柔而坚定的一种样貌
那对我个人本身
我自己本身我没有什么困扰
因为这就是我
那我会比较困扰的是
就是
就是嗯大众如果觉得说哎呀
你是不是应该转个型啊
你是不是应该换个什么样子
你是不是应该这个比会让我比较困扰
比较纠结
是绵绵的糖
哦我知道了
你喜欢上我了
我拼凑出天猫
我看根本就是厚脸
明天晚上差不多
爱小爱心
我叫陶爱卿
不叫小爱卿
干嘛要买冰淇淋用
那时候我看过一个台剧叫做微笑花絮才好
这个角色跟你自己是比较像这样的吗
还是说有的去寻找他的
跟我自己现在是有点遥远了
但是他大概是我可以想象17 8年前的事情了
就像当时的对
跟当时的我
我觉得没有一个角色会跟自己完全想象的
嗯嗯但是如果跟我那几年的那几部天国的嫁衣
微笑百事达
桃花小妹这三步相较起来的话
可能微笑百事达会比较接近当时的我一些嗯
我记得他就是比较比较阳光正面
然后对事情啊充满积极跟不气馁跟希望
笑一笑
没什么事情
过不了笑一笑
大不了就有时候我有时候我我是这样子的
有时候我是这样的
可以聊聊当时的张国良
这些特色都是栋梁啊
就
是我前阵子碰到他
我觉得他他
就是反正我们两个就是长大之后更近了
也许那个时候真的是很忙
这个礼拜一拍
礼拜六要播的
所以大家其实是在一个工作很忙碌
然后蛮高压的一个状态
所以大家必须一天到底是背本啊还是什么的
那我觉得真正有相处反而是长大之后对
那我觉得长大之后觉得她还是一样
是那个笑起来很让我感到很阳光温暖的大男孩
对
然后反而我们就是聊的东西
真的跟小时候聊的不一样
但是不是不方便跟你们讲的
哈哈哈嗯像我们那时候录节目的时候
他可能因为他他我是因为经过姐姐的洗礼
所以我本来也是非常不喜欢真人秀的拍摄方
然后那我们因为那个节目要相处了好几天
然后他其实变的是他的第一次的真人秀
好吧
很紧张
这样后来我就跟他说
不用怕有我在这样
他顿时觉得我给他很多安全感
其实我虽然看是一个娇弱需要照顾的女子
那其实我也可以跟他说
不怕有我在怕什么
然后对
所以我们就是后来他就说哦
他渐渐渐渐就是就是在录制的过程中就蛮放松
也还是那个蛮可爱的人啊
其实你最开始是演电视剧的
演台剧演的几部也都非常的受欢迎
也是感觉好像为什么后面没有怎么演了
还是重心更多的放在了一片上面
其实我从小就是爱唱歌跳舞
喜欢音乐
我觉得受妈妈影响应该蛮大的
对他非常会唱歌
家里都是他的奖杯都是第一名了
我没有第二名
然后嗯我觉得我的天生的节奏感
遗传他的吧
我觉得嗯所以我从小就喜欢唱歌表演
以歌手身份正式出道之后
才又去演那个天国的嫁衣
才要去演当时很火的偶像剧
就那段时间偶像剧
我觉得就是真的很辉煌的一段时间
那时候我有对
我有就是有参与到好几次这样孤独中绝望
在绝望中坚强
请讲后继续不停想着她
到后来我觉得我还是就是一定要我选的话
就这两个表演工作
我还是最喜欢唱歌和跳舞
我觉得在舞台上的我是最从容自在的
然后这这这几年真的也是重心比较放在
歌手的身份
所以突然要我去演戏
我可能还会有点紧张
我觉得然后偶尔就是可能拍mv的时候过过戏瘾
嗯对这对现在的阶段呢
你来说偶像这个剧本可能你觉得不是很合适了
也没有
我觉得可能要看那个角色的设定
角色的设定
因为偶像剧还是偶像剧存在的意义
可是他的拍摄手法还是蛮偶像剧的呀
那那种可能也可以
现在沈阳怎样的节奏被打动到
你打到现在的
如果偶像剧的话
我觉得那个韩剧那个酒鬼
都市女人们就蛮有趣的
很轻松
有时候也会小酌一下
发生一些好玩的趣事
就是他的故事
我觉得那时候看的时候觉得很轻松
也很有趣
都快忘了怎样恋一个爱
我被虚度了的青青春
也许还能活过来
说心疼我的更应该明白
那是给自己设一个目标
就是要完成什么样的事情
我做这个专辑要达到什么样的销量
或者是拿到奖嗯
或者参加一个节目要拿到什么样的人
小时候当然会觉得我也要像那个明星一样
30岁以后就还好
但不是说不觉觉得哦就可以不努力就可以摆烂
就就就可以就随便
不是
而是说我的性格
我一定会尽力去做好我该做的事情
然后其他的我就会觉得顺其自然
嗯刚刚说到的这个节点就是30岁
30岁为什么是这个节点
我觉得30岁之后
渐渐的可以开始放慢一些脚步了
聪明的环境也一样
因为从cd啊
然后到数位啊
我工作的早期的发片的那个紧密度
跟后来其实不太一样
所以让我整体可以放慢脚步
让我放慢脚步之后
我有空间去呃balance我的工作跟我的生活
我的家人
我的朋友
当放慢一些脚步的时候
对于很多事情就是嗯会去努力
然后也会希望拿到好的成绩
好的或者是好的结果对
但是不会去像一头猛兽一样的去争
就是反正就是一步一步地做好自己
早年间还是有点像猛兽的是吧
在空岛上
但是其实我的个性也不会太像猛兽
可能就是像一只很凶的猫
而且很凶的猫
猛兽不全
现在猫咪已经把它的爪牙收起来了
猫咪猫那只猫咪也蛮少露出爪牙的
然后现在爪牙又磨得更平了
所以您年纪为什么出到外国的周年
有什么样的计划呢
我们本来在我20周年的时候
就会就本来就在计划新的专辑20周年的专辑
然后那时候是因为其实是因为乘风破浪
我们稍微停摆了一下
我们在来之前在台北已经在收割了
然后嗯决定过来的时候就就就先站快
前阵子就回去了
台北就是又重新再做了一下
专辑的歌曲的一些确认和调整
毕竟20周年
我觉得这个是一个长大成人的年纪
哈哈出道20周年
满20岁的这个是很重要的1年
所以我觉得接下来应该就是
全心投入在新的专辑
那现在呢你都不20岁左右
当时到的时候
他们他音乐对你的意义有什么变化
对我的意义其实没有变化
就是因为对我来讲
他就是在我生活中很自然的一件事情
就跟喝水一般
自然睡前要听音乐
化妆要听音乐
起床要听音乐
刚刚一路走过来
想说拍照有点音乐好像也可以
对他就是这么自然的
在我的生活中
从我小的时候到现在都一样
我觉得音乐可以
可以疗愈人的心情
对不同的时候放不同的音乐
然后你可以被音乐治愈20种
临床平认为是一个时间节点
所以到现在的这几个
当年有一个什么样的大的变化
总是会有变化啦
就是可能小时候的样子
跟现在的样子也会有点不太一样
这个是对啊
然后呃想法上也会不太一样
嗯你对工作的想法
以前可能你就是听着做
然后现在会有自己的想法
有更多的讨论
包含我觉得眼神都不太一样
你20岁的眼神跟40岁的眼神
跟人家对谈的时候
那自然的眼神绝对不一样
20岁的专辑封面的眼神
跟现在专辑封面的眼神就不一样了
20岁一定就是最单纯
最单纯
最直接
现在多了一层柔和温柔
成熟温柔
哈哈哈哈哈啊